good morning John most of you 99% aren't
gonna be able to be at VidCon and so you
don't want to hear about how great it's
gonna be so in lieu of being VidCon or
even if you are gonna be there I'm gonna
give you an assignment
VidCon is all about celebrating and
appreciating the culture of online video
but as John you so wisely pointed out
last video we're pretty old the first
time I got obsessed with a video I
downloaded from the internet was 1998
the year before that was when the very
first viral internet video happened uh
it was just this dancing baby except you
got to go watch Chaka ooga ooga ooga
Chaka ooga ooga ooga ooga SPECT I have
been into online video for longer than
some of you have been in the world which
makes me ina depressed but it also might
actually make me that elusive thing an
expert so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna listen to me talk about how
great the old days were and then you're
gonna indulge me by going to watch a
bunch of old online video that I think
is better than anything being created
today despite mounds of evidence to the
contrary it's just like any other course
you've ever taken dancing baby is not in
the category of things that I think are
really fantastic and great but a couple
years later in the year 2000 a project
was launched that became the best and
remains the best online video project in
history Homestar Runner is some kind of
bizarre alien thing that lives in free
country USA with his friends his
girlfriend marzipan who was baseball bat
with hair in a dress coach Z and pom pom
and the cheat and Kingstown and strong
mad who's just a square and strong sad
who is sad and circular and strong bad
who despite having boxing gloves for
hands types out responses to emails
every week there's so much good Homestar
Runner content you need to grab a friend
and take them and take this wonderful
thing that exists into your life it's
really good homestar runner comm check
it out and note that when we started
watching that show that little thing
took off our entire come
pewter monitors and then weep for us as
a kid just fell off a bike outside of my
window he's okay he's fun at the same
time his Homestar Runner there was all
kinds of really interesting flash
animation stuff happen in the end of the
world all your base are belong to us
peanut butter jelly time these are
things that are important pieces of the
culture of the internet he also got what
was probably the first Internet native
genre of video the ANA mutation enemies
Asians were brought in the world by a
lot of different people but they were
pioneered by a guy who you might know
from his later work the mysterious
ticking noise
Nilsa serega but when bandwidth got good
enough people could actually start to
send and receive video this kind of
video I'm the most important video
series of all time was of course the
show with Zay Frank the show
revolutionized video it took advantage
of the fact that the Internet is a
two-way medium it allowed people to
participate in the project it wasn't
just about say it was about the entire
sports racer community pretty much
anything you want on YouTube nowadays is
either directly or indirectly influenced
by Jose Frank all the stuff was
extremely important in the Internet's
ability to establish itself as its own
standalone legitimate culture and since
YouTube came along yes many more amazing
things have happened so much amazing
stuff is being made now that of course I
can't even start to talk about what's
happened since YouTube existed this is
almost a kind of prehistory of internet
video that I'm talking about right now
and I think that it's important for us
to understand that stuff for us to know
where it all came from also it's just
amazingly fun to enjoy so grab a friend
click the links in the description and
just enjoy now I have to go back to
VidCon stuff I want this video to keep
going I want to keep making this video
wanna choke on Vick okay I'm gonna do it
though John I'll see you on Tuesday